tasked with uncovering the source of an
urgent NSA security alert agents make
their way through to a facility that is
based beneath the National Mall
navigating the corridors they come up
against the Black Tusk but what are they
doing down there
[Music]
beneath the National Mall an urgent
security alert from the NSA has caught
the attention of division agents
their mission to is investigate the
source of this alarming signal and
uncover the truth lurking beneath the
surface
the Agents set out to locate the origin
of the security alert following a trail
of Clues they navigate through the
complex corridors and passages making
their way deeper into the facility
as they delve further they encounter
locked doors and restricted areas
to gain access the agents must showcase
their expertise hacking systems and
override security measures to reach the
heart of the operation
inside the Hub room agents secure the
area Embrace themselves for what lies
ahead
they press forward onto the generator
room where they face another challenge
the power is out and the Agents must
restore it to proceed they reactivate
the generator and replace the
malfunctioning fuse the lights flicker
back to life Illuminating their path
forward
their Journey leads them to the data
center where crucial information awaits
to access it the agents must locate a
keycard
once found they breach the data Center's
defenses and reboot the servers
unlocking a wealth of valuable
intelligence
however their progress does not go
unnoticed the black task launches an
assault on the agents testing their
resilience and combat skills
amidst the chaos the agents fight back
determined to secure the data center and
protect the valuable information Within
the agents were able to repel the Black
Tusk assault and then regroup The Hub
ensuring the computer systems are all
secured and the facility is under their
control
as they exit the facility the division
agents carry with them the Intel they
have obtained in understanding the
gravity of the situation hit directly to
the White House to analyze it
that's so interesting Professor
long-term survival depends on evolution
the common cold used to Cull the weak
those who survived were stronger and
went on to breed the Next Generation and
so on Darwin sure but you see we
short-circuited this evolution
we developed drugs that keep those who
should have died from dying we've
artificially propped up the weak for
over a century so what's the answer
eugenics
not at all
I don't think we should have any choice
in who lives and who dies Humanity can't
be trusted
transitions people will always find a
way to gain the system to capitalize on
it to commodify it like big Pharma
exactly an entire industry devoted to
keeping sick people artificially alive
in order to exploit them the more pills
you take the more money they make more
people overcrowd the planet and more
people pollute the world it's not
sustainable you're right
it's not
yeah kind of a genius I'm just a guy who
sees the big picture
Stacy Chen engages in an intriguing
conversation with Professor Gordon
Amherst who expresses his disbelief in
the disruption of Natural Evolution due
to Modern medicine's ability to prolong
the lives of the weak
they discussed the dangers of human
intervention the exploitation of the
pharmaceutical industry and the
unsustainable consequences of a crowded
and polluted world
in this exchange Amherst sees himself as
someone who perceives the broader
perspective on these matters
this is likely to have taken place
months if not longer before Amherst
finalized the green poison virus and
released it onto the world
this particular recording is labeled as
Gordon Amherst recording 118. so the NSA
had been watching him for a while so
how's he able to get away with what he
would eventually do or is this a
situation where someone higher up would
bury these recordings and allow him to
finish his work
come on you can spare three samples yeah
but I'll pay you look 2 000 U.S wire
transfer or crypto I need them sent to
La by Monday it's not that easy I can't
throw a couple vials in a padded
envelope and put it in the mail put them
in a box with dry ice and overnight the
package Customs won't let a package from
Russia into the U.S if the dry ice melts
the h3n6 samples will start to Decay at
-80 don't worry I'll take care of
Customs do we have a deal what do you
need these for I was using the h3n7 but
my subjects kept dying I need the h3n6
it's got a longer incubation period
Ivan desperately seeks three samples of
h3n6 offering a substantial payment to
Nadia
however logistical challenges arrive as
Nadia explains the complexities of
shipping the samples including Customs
restrictions and the delicate nature of
the virus
despite the risks Ivan is determined to
obtain the samples for his research
citing the longer incubation period as a
crucial factor for his experiments
it's difficult to tell but given that
this recording was bundled together with
the last one it's possible that Ivan was
working with Amherst or as at least
assisting him with finding the virus
samples he needs
also he doesn't seem particularly
concerned with customs so again maybe
he's being directed by someone further
up who's able to bypass these security
measures
[Music]
the hearing is destroying the planet
I know babe the planet delete
everything and flood the world with GMO
cork as long as they can make another
million who cares if we all burn
can't let them get to you we gotta do
something real let's go to the meeting a
meeting I told you that group I joined
online they've got a planning meeting
they're not just sitting on their asses
waiting for the world to burn they're
planning on making real change
you don't mean those guys who burn down
all those trees because they were
hybrids they were Abominations
Erica expresses frustration with
bioengineering's negative impact on the
planet criticizing the disregard for
environmental consequences in the
pursuit of profit
Michael tries to console her but Erica
remains determined to take action she
mentions an online group she joined
planning to make substantial changes
rather than passively accepting the
world's destruction
this one doesn't seem to have as much in
relation to the other two but it does
give an example of many other groups
that think along similar lines to
Amherst that maybe haven't quite gotten
to the point of working towards the
larger scale eco-terrorism at least not
yet anyway
I quite like this one particularly the
comms around Gordon Amherst yet again it
shows a different angle to even the
previous assignments from a time before
the outbreak eco-terrorists and even the
man who started it all
I would love to see more of these
recordings from Amherst just to help
build the scene before he finally
decided to create the virus and all of
the people who may be assisted in
pushing him in this direction those with
much different plans in mind
in fact a prequel to The Division one
would be amazing I'm not sure what sort
of game that could be but even a short
series would be awesome I Can Dream
anyway I hope you've enjoyed this thank
you very much for watching and extremist
malice extreme remedia
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you